شكرا لميسون اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نتابع واياكم تغطيه العربيه المكثفه
والمتواصله للمحاكمه التاريخيه للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونا طبعا محاكمه تاريخيه
مشهد يختلط فيه القانوني مع السياسي في ظل
مثول رئيس سابق للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه امام محكمه جنائيه ونشاهد هذه
الصور لترامب من داخل المحكمه
قبل قليل تزوير سجلته التجاريه قبل
انتخابات 20 سته عشر والمحكمه رفعت السريه
عن لائحه الاتهام ضد ترامب وفقا
وتضمنت هذه اللائحه تقديم ريشه لشراء سكوت
امراه تاين اضافه الى اتهام ترامب بالتامل
اذا مدعي عام من هاتا يتهم ترامب بالتامر
وفقا لام بي سي نيوز نذكر ايضا بانه
ذكرت تقديم ريشه لشراء السقوط امراتين
وكانت زعيمه التجمع والتكتل الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب اعتبرت اعتقال ترامب بانه
وصفته بانه امر مخزن وتنضم الينا للتعليق
على هذا اليوم التاريخي كما يوصف من
نيويورك مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن
ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك ناديه يعني بدايه
رفعت السريه عن لائحه الاتهامات كيف يمكن
وصفها في ظل نفي ترامب لاي من التهم
الموجهه ضده
طبعا خلال فتره وجيزه سيتم نشر كل هذه
الاتهامات الاربعه وثلاثين على الموقع
الالكتروني للمحكمه وبالتالي يستطيع اي
شخص سواء كان مواطن امريكي عادي او اي
مكان في العالم ان يقرا هذه الاتهامات
وبالتفاصيل حتى الان لم تنشر حتى هذه
اللحظه ثانيا المراه الاخرى تحدثنا عنها
ربما في النشرات السابقه وكانت ايضا موضع
حديث واتهام وهي كريم مكذوب قيل ايضا بان
الترامب حاول شراء صمتها وانه دفع لها
اموال ومره اخرى بالفعل نرى بان المدعي
العام في نيويورك يضيف اسمها الى اسم
ستورميدانيوس موضوع ايضا تزوير الوثائق
التجاريه يبدو بانه ضمن هذه الاتهامات
يعني حتى الان الى ان نطلع بالتفاصيل على
الاتهامات 34 نستطيع ان نقول بانه لا يوجد
يعني مفاجات وليس هناك ايضا مفاجاه
بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب بانه قال بانه غير
مذنب لكن نركز على نقطه مهمه بانه الرئيس
ترامب كان معتقل كان معتقل اتى الى
المحكمه طواعيه لكن لو لم ياتي كان بامكان
شرطه نيويورك ان تقوم باعتقالي في منزله
او حتى شرطه فلوريدا رغم ان حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا انه لن يتعاون مع العملاء
الفيدراليين في اعتقال الرئيس السابق لكن
بغض النظر ما نراه اليوم وهذه اللحظه هو
ان الرئيس ترامب يدخل التاريخ بهذه
السابقه بانه بانه رئيس كانت قد تم
اعتقاله قبل قليل طبعا قرات عليه ما يسمى
بحقوقه القانونيه وهي هذه الادعاءات دفع
الكفاله وخرج من المحكمه كان في داخل
المحكمه ثلاثه من محاميه المقربين
وكانوا معه طوال الوقت معه ايضا ليله امس
في برج اكرم لمراجعه الخطوات القادمه
الرئيس سياسيا سيستفيد من هذه المحاكمه
لتجنيد مناصرين ومؤيدين جدد للحصول على
دعم لحملات الانتخابيه لكن بالصوره الاكبر
اعتقديه اكثر تعقيدا بالنسبه لموقع قد
يكون هو مرشح الجمهوريين في الانتخابات
القادمه لكن بالنسبه لباقي الامريكيين هل
يستطيع ترامب ان يحصل على اصوات مستقلين
اصوات المشككين به اصوات المعتدلين هذا هو
سؤال الاكبر ربما وقد يحرموا هذا بالفعل
من الفوز مره اخرى في الانتخابات القادمه
على الصعيد القانوني ناديه بغض النظر عن
اراء الناس او الناخبين على الصعيد
القانوني المحض هذا لن يؤثر عليه حتى لو
ادين يعني لا استدعاء ولا محاكمته ولا
ادانته ويمكن للحزب الجمهوري ان يتبنى
ترشيحه فعلا وان يشارك في هذه الانتخابات
بغض النظر عن النتائج
الرئيس ان يشارك في هذه الانتخابات
والقانون الامريكي غريب نوعا ما يعني
ربما قد نعتقد بانه حتى الاشخاص العاديين
دون خلفيه قانونيه بانه اي شخص اذينا
بجريمه لن يستطيع ان يشارك في الانتخابات
لكن نسبه القانون الامريكي لكي تكون مرشح
للرئاسه يجب ان يكون عمرك 35 عاما ان تكون
مواطنا امريكيا ولد في الولايات المتحده
ولا يكون لديك مشاكل عقليه لكن عدا عن
السجل القانوني لا يدخل في ضمن الاعتبارات
لكن هذا سيؤثر عليه يعني اضاءه وضعنا
القانون والنصب القانوني جانبا اكيد سيؤثر
على الرئيس لكن ايضا هو سيستفيد منه لانه
هو الذي يستفيد من كل الازمات يحولها الى
فرص حتى هذه الصوره الجنائيه التي تسمى
بماكشون تاكدي بنا ستطبع على تيشرت وستباع
لجمع ارباح لحملته الانتخابيه
وهو يلوح وهو يرفع قبضته يعني هذه القبضه
التي عاده ترتبط بالتحدي بالنسبه
للامريكيين اصول افريقيه بالنسبه
الذي يشعرون بالظلم في دول العالم الثالث
الذين يريدون يناضلون من اجل القضيه لكن
لا نطبقها على رئيس سابق او على الذين
ينحذرون من اصول انجلوساكسونيه مثل
الرئيسيه فقط جيفاريه اكثر الذين عاده
يتحدثون النضال تماما هي نضاليه بالدرجه
الاولى وربما يقول بانني افوز رغم كل هذه
الظروف يتحدى العالم يتحدى الديمقراطيين
ويتحدى القضاء بهذه القبضه ناديه كيف يمكن
وصف حاله الجمهوريين خلال وجود ودخول
ترامب الى المحكمه يعني هل تم رصد اي
حالات شغب ويعني شيء غير متوقع منهم
لا على الاطلاق مؤيدي الرئيس ومعارضيه وهم
تقريبا بالعشرات قد يصلوا الى المئه لكن
ليس باعداد كبيره جدا
هم يعني يرفعون الشعارات المعتاده سواء
كان المعارض او المؤيد لكن يوجد اي احيانا
مشدات كلاميه ليس اكثر لكن شرطه وعدت كل
شخص يقلب الانف بان يتم اعتقاله كان وجود
تاييد للرئيس من قبل نواب مثلا
وهي نائبه متطرفه يمينيه تحسب على ترامب
منذ البدايه اتت الى هنا كانت في ساعات
الصباح وايضا جورج سانتوس وهو ايضا نائب
متطرف وغير معترف في من قبل الكثيرين بانه
زور تاريخه وسجل حتى يحصل على هذا المقعد
وهو ايضا من يور اتى لتاييد ترامب عدا عن
هذا لم نسمع اصوات اخرى طبعا بعض
الجمهوريه التقليديين مثل الذي دعم الرئيس
وايضا مايك بانس وحتى حاكم فلوريدج رو ند
سادس كلهم يدعمون رئيس تاييد في داخل حزب
الجمهوري مرتفع اكثر
حساباتهم الانتخابيه ناديه اليس كذلك هم
ايضا لديهم حساباتهم الانتخابيه
تماما
بالتاكيد لانه لانه اذا في حال عدم ترشح
ترامب للانتخابات الاوليه في الحزب
الجمهوري ليصبح مرشح الجمهوريين هم يريدون
الحفاظ على القاعده الشعبيه التي تدعم
ترامب وهي قاعده كبيره 30% من الحزب
الجمهوريه دعم ترامب ويقف معه لا نعرف اذا
سيذهبون ويغيرون ربما ولائهم من ترامب الى
مرشح جمهوري اخر لا نعرف لكن على الاقل
هناك كما ذكرت بالتحديد طاهر حسابات حزبيه
سياسيه بامتياز يعني لا شيء هنا غير ملون
بلون الانتهازيه اذا اردت والفرص السياسيه
التي يمكن ان تتماخذ عنها هذه المحاكمه هل
كان الهدوء الجمهوري او ترامبي من مناصرين
مرتبط فقط
بتهديدات الشرطه او بعدم اراده الجمهوريين
والترامبيين ان يكرروا
مشاهد جديده من احداث
السادس من يناير 2021
اولا هم لم ياتوا باعداد كبيره الى مقارنه
على الاطلاق ما بين 100 شخص يعني بالمجمل
مع عشرات الالاف الذين كانوا في محيط
الكونغرس وانا كنت اذكر هذا اليوم
بالتحديد كنا نغطيه على الهواء مباشره
وتحول الى احداث عنف ادت الى مقتل خمس
اشخاص لكن طبعا هناك احترازات امنيه اكيد
اي شرطه في اي ولايه امريكيه شرطه يعني
متمكنه كثيرا هناك اعداد كبيره منهم
الجمهوريه او حزبيه بهذا المعنى يعني كان
في تعليمات واضحه او لا يعني اتت الامور
هكذا
لا لم تكن يعني لم تكن تعليمات واضحه لكن
الرئيس نفسه رغم انه اعلم مناصري بانه
ستكون المحاكمه يوم الثلاثاء قبل اسبوعين
طبعا اختلف الوقت باسبوعين لكن رغم ذلك لم
نرى اعداد تتدفق باصات وناقلات وحافلات
تاتي الى نيويورك مظاهرات محدوده تدعموه
لكنها محدوده عدد ابقي معنا ناديه ابقي
معنا ننوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل بايدن
يرفض الرد على اسئله الصحفيين حول اتهام
ترامب خلال فعاليه حول الذكاء الاصطناعي
كان هناك فعاليه ورفض التعليق على الموضوع
تنضم الينا من
كونجرس من الكونجرس ريتا سليمان مراسله
العربيه ايضا في هذه التغطيه الخاصه اهلا
بك ريتا يعني
تعليق
العاصمه الان المواقف الصادره من العاصمه
الامريكيه حول هذا اليوم التاريخي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دعيني ابدا بتصريح البيت الابيض المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض في ايجازها الصحفي
اليومي اعتبرت بانه الرئيس بايدن على
اجندته
ملفات ليتابعها وهو ليس مهتما على الاطلاق
بما يحصل في نيويورك وخاصه محاكمه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ايضا اعتبرت كريم
جانبير بانه الرئيس بايدن علم بهذه القضيه
من من وسائل الاعلام تحديدا وهو ونفت ايضا
ان يكون له اي علاقه
بهذا التصعيد من قبل المدعي العام في
ولايات نيويورك حول هذه القضيه تحديدا
والان في هذه الفعاليه حول الذكاء
الاصطناعي رفض الرئيس جو بايدن التعليق
على هذه القضيه وما حصل اليوم ايضا في
ولايه نيويورك وفي المحاكمه
يحاول الرئيس تجنب ان يكون له حتى ولو
تعليق على هذه القضيه لانه يعرف تماما
بانه اي تعلي يستخدم ضده هو الان في هذه
النقطه بالذات
اذا سمحتي لي المرحله المقبله
يقول سالت بايدن حول ما اذا كانت اتهام
ترامب سياسيا فابتسم ولم يرد ايضا حول هذه
النقطه بعدما كان رفض الرد على اسئله
الصحفيين كما قلنا ولكن الجديد الان بانه
المراسل مراسل سي بي اس نيوز يقول ابتسم
ولكن لم يرد هو كما قلنا بالامس يحاول مع
بقيه اعضاء الاداره ان ينائى بنفسه عن هذا
الموضوع كي لا يتهم بتسييس القضاء ريتا
ماذا عن قيادات ابرز قيادات الكونجرس من
الحزبين وابرز تصريحاتهم حول هذا الموضوع
تحديدا حول هذه المحاكمه
الجميع حاول النائبه نفسه عن ما يحصل الان
في نيويورك على الرغم من انه الجميع
يتابعها حتى الموظفون هنا في الكونغرس
تابعنا رايناهم على هواتفهم يحاولون تتبع
وسائل الاعلام عما يحصل في نيويورك
تصريح الابرز ربما كان لزعيمه ديمقراطيين
الذي اعتبر بانه هذا مسار العداله ولا احد
فوق القانون نفس التصريح الذي دائما ما
يلجا اليه الديمقراطيون في هذه القضيه
اليوم وفي الايام السابقه التي سبقت ايضا
هذه المحاكمه
هناك ايضا السيناتور الجمهوري
روبيو الذي يعتبر بانه ما يحصل الان هو
منحه تاريخي ستنظم الولايات المتحده على
اليوم الذي يمثل فيه الرئيس دونالد ترامب
امام القضاء
هذا ربما تصريح لمسانده الرئيس ولكن دائما
الجمهوريون اكتفوا بالتصريحات المسانده
وهم بكل تصريحاتهم يعودون الى الشارع
ويقولون ولكن لا يجب ان نذهب بالعنف الى
الشوارع لدعم الرئيس ترامب بكل تصريحاتهم
لابد ان تنتهي تصريحاتهم بهذه العباره نعم
ابقي معنا ريتا نذكر طاهر بانه ترامب نفا
انه مذنب في 34 اتهاما وجهها اليه من قبل
القاضي خلال مثوله اليوم امام المحكمه في
منهات واعود اليك ناديه ناديه يعني نشاهد
هذه الصور لدخول ترامب وتواجده من داخل
المحكمه وقد وصلت لكل وسائل الاعلام منذ
قليل كان هناك طلب من وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه بان تبث
هذه المحكمه على الهواء ولكن تم الرفض وتم
الاكتفاء بسماح للمصورين باخذ صور فقط
ببدايات الجلسه لماذا ماذا كانت تب رير
عاده في المحاكم الامريكيه بشكل عام لا
يوجد هناك الجلسات متلفزه يعني انا اذكر
عندما كنا نغطي احداث المحاكمه المتهمين
باحداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر لا يوجد هناك
على الاطلاق ولا حتى صور فوتوغرافيه كان
احيانا يكون فقط رسام ياخذ هذه الصور
وبالتالي اجراء معتاد يعني لم يتم عمل
استثناء بطلب
للمحطات الامريكيه او وسائل الاعلام لان
هناك اهتمام هذا ليس بمتهم عادي مواطن
عادي هذا رئيس امريكي سابق وهو يسجل سابقه
في التاريخ لذا كان هناك حرص من وسائل
الاعلام على الطلب من
القاضي ومن المحكمه ان تسمح على الاقل
ربما لوسيله اعلام واحده يمكن ان توزع
الصور على الجميع لكن القاضي لم يقوم بهذا
الاستثناء
وربما فضل ان لانه الشخصيه هي رئيس سابق
يتم الامر فقط من خلال وجود بعض الصور
الفوتوغرافيه لا اعرف ما هي حسابات القاضي
لكنه امر غير يعني ليس بعادي الاستثناء هو
بالفعل ان يسمح للكاميرات بان تدخل الى
المكان
التبقينا معنا ناديه واريتا ونتحول الى
بير غانم مراسل العربيه من واشنطن
اهلا بك كيف تتابع من جانبك اخر المعطيات
حول هذه المحاكمه ما ابرز النقاط التي يجب
ان نتنبه لها وربما قد استمعت الى ابرز ما
جاء حتى الان في هذه الساعه
نعطي بعض التفاصيل المهمه بالنسبه لما
يحدث الان في نيويورك وما يمكن
ان بعد ذلك الان الجميع ينتظر هذه اللائحه
من الاتهامات من المرجح وبحسب الكثير من
المصادر القضائيه والاعلاميه والسياسيه
انما حدث هو توجيه اتهامات للرئيس السابق
من انه سهل وصول اموال الى الممثله
الاباحيه لشراء سكوتها ولكن ليس هذا هو
المقصود بالاتهامات المقصود بالاتهامات هو
انه صار هناك تزوير للسجلات التجاريه
واخفاء القصد الاساسي من تحويل هذه
الاموال الى المحامي ومن قبل ذلك من
المحامي الى هذه الممثله كل
القضائيه تتحدث الان بصرف النظر عن الرقم
الموجود لهذه الاتهامات 34 او 33 او 35 ان
هذه القضيه هي القضيه الاقل اهميه القضيه
الاهم سوف تكون نتيجه التحقيقات التي تقوم
بها وزاره العدل الامريكيه في علاقه
دونالد ترامب بالهجوم على مبنى الكونجرس
في اليوم الذي كان من المفترض ان يتم
الاعلان عن نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الرسميه وسوف تكون هناك قضيه اخرى في
جورجيا حول هذه القضيه ايضا هناك قضيه
رابعه وبدات تظهر بعض تفاصيلها وهي ان
المحقق يتحدث الان على ان دونالد ترامب
بالفعل كان يحاول عرقله عمل السلطه عندما
كان يحاول ان يمتنع عن تسليم الوثائق
السريه التي كانت بحوزته من قبل
الاستخبارات الامريكيه حول قضايا كثيره
ومنها ملفات سريه حول القضايا نعم النوويه
ما نشهدها الان في نيويورك هو في مصلحه
دونالد ترامب لان الاعلام الامريكي كله
يعطيه الوقت الكامل ليظهر
الناخبين الامريكيين وسوف يستغل ايضا ظهور
بعد قليل في مره لاغو في فلوريدا ليؤكد
لناخذيه انه هو الشخص القائد وليس فقط
الشخص الذي يقف امام المحكمه ابيار يعني
حتى ولو لم تعرقل المشكلات القانونيه او
ما يواجهه دونالد ترامب من اتهامات عودته
السياسيه والترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه الى
اي مدى هذه الاتهامات يمكن ان تضر
بالمرشحين الجمهوريين الاخرين
خلال الايام الماضيه كان واضحا منذ تم
الاعلان يوم الخميس مساء على ان هيئه
المحلفين قد وصلت وصوتت بالفعل على لائحه
اتهامات كان هناك كلام كثير على ان
الاشخاص الذين كانوا في الوسط ويحاولون
التقرب من المرشحين مثل حاكم
بداوا بالعوده مره اخرى باتجاه دونالد
ترامب الكثير من الجمهوريين يعتبرون ان
دونالد ترامب هو مستهدف في عمليه سياسيه
حيث يستعمل الديمقراطيون القضاء للقضاء
عليه في هذه القضيه وبالتالي هي ليست قضيه
عداله بل استهداف سياسي شعبيه ترامب بشكل
عام كانت ثابته خلال الاسبوع الماضيه وهي
حوالي اربعين في المئه بالنسبه
مازال عالقا عند مستوى العشرين في المئه
دولار ما زال المرشح المفضل لدى
الجمهوريين والاهم من ذلك هو ان قاعده
ترامب الصلبه تزداد ص وتزداد اكثر حماسه
لان ترى ان الديمقراطيين هم الذين
يستهدفون هذا المرشح الجمهوري تبقى معنا
غانم اذا مؤتمر صحفي مرتقب لمدعي عام من
هاتن الفن براج حول قضيه بعد قليل بانتظار
ان يعود ايضا ترامب الى فلوريدا وان نستمع
الى كلمته لاحقا هذه الليله طبعا كما قلنا
بانه
نفى لائحه الاتهام دفع ببراءته تحديدا
تزوير سجلته التجاريه قبل انتخابات 2016
الموضوع الاساسي متعلق طبعا راويه لم يصرح
عن هذا المبلغ تحديدا 130 الف دولار
بحسابات حملته الانتخابيه قبل الانتخابات
2016 وهذا هو انتهاك اساسي بغض النظر عما
اذا كان منح الاموال بحد ذاته ممكن او لا
صحيح وهذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لمدعي عامه
يعني وهو لانه ديمقراطي هو وجهت الي عده
انتقادات ان كان من الرئيس السابق المتهم
دون الترامب او من الجمهوريين ويعني تم
اعتبار هذه القضيه بانها يعني اتهام سياسي
ومسيسه وليست قانونيه بحث على كل الاحوال
نعود الى شبكه مراسلينا والى نادي
البلبيسي ناديه يعني الملاحظ بانه اليوم
دونالد ترامب وصل الى محكمه منهات وحيدا
دون اي من افراد اسرته فقط مع الحرس يعني
عاده
المسانده العائليه تكون مهمه في هكذا
حالات خاصه بقضيه متعلقه بممثله اباحيه
ومعروف هذه المعايير كم هي مهمه للمجتمع
والراي العام الامريكي
يعني من المفروض ان تكون هذه القضيه محرجه
لمؤيدي ومناصري الرئيس يعني كنا نتحدث عن
حجم التاييد له لنذكر بانه متهم بانه دفع
اموال وقام علاقه جنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
ليس مع حتى امراه عاديه لكن مع امراه تمثل
في افلام اباحيه يعني هذا بحد ذاته يجب ان
يعطي ربما
نقطه
للتفكير بالنسبه للمؤيدين وخصوصا
الانجيليين المسيحيين الذين يؤيدونه بشكل
اعمى يعني هذه الحزب الجمهوري يمثل الاسره
يمثل المفاهيم المحافظه المبادئ وبالتالي
حتى الموضوع نفسه يجب ان يكون موضع موضع
سجالي راينا بان ملانه لم تاتي معه وهو
الفتره الزمنيه التي اقام هذه العلاقه
وهذا الاسم الذي تستخدمه هو
بعد ان كان قد انجبت ابنه بارين وهو الابن
الوحيد الذي
يجمعهما ملاني ترامب ايضا ابنته ايفانكا
التي لعبت دور حاسم ومهم في الانتخابات
السابقه وكانت بمثابه بمثابه ذراعه اليمنى
وجاريت كوشر ايضا صيره كانوا دوما يدعمون
الرئيس غابوا عن
على تغريده لافانكا قبل يومين تقريبا قالت
بانني اصلي من اجل ابي او احب ابي واحب
بلدي ايضا وكانها اشاره ايضا لما يحدث في
البلاد لم نرى ايضا ابنائي السابق يخرج
الان من قاعه المحاكمه في نيويورك على ان
يتوجه ويعود الى فلوريدا حيث سنستمع الى
كلمه له ولاحقا هذه الليله يمكن ان نعيد
هذه الصور مره اخرى اذا نعيدها عليكم مره
اخرى الرئيس ترامب يبدو رئيس السابق يبدو
خارج ا من قاعه المحكمه ومن خلفه بعض ممن
كانوا في داخلها بعد ما نفى لائحه الاتهام
التي وجهت اليها اذا مشهد تاريخي طاهر
نشاهد ترامب يخرج من قاعه المحكمه بعد يوم
طويل وجهت خلاله من قبل محاكمات منهاتن
لائحه الاتهامات لائحه الاتهامات التي
رفضها بكل تفاصيلها طبعا لائحه الاتهام
تتضمن تقديم روشا لشراء سكوت امراتين
وايضا تزوير سجلاته التجاريه قبل انتخابات
عام 2016
كله بالسريال قال بانه يعني لا اصدق بانه
هذا يحصل في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يبدو الامر سورياليا للغايه يا للهول سيتم
توقيفي لا اصدق ان هذا يحدث في امريكا انا
ذاهب الى المحكمه كان كتب ذلك على تشوث
سوشيال خرج الان من المحكمه اذن هذه
الصوره من الجانب الذي هو خارج المحكمه في
الهواء الطلق الان قبل ان يستقل موكبه
مجددا الى المطار ليعود الى فلوريدا
طبعا سيكون هناك تصريح له من مارالاجو حيث
يتواجد مقره كان هناك تصريح اضافي لترامب
في وصف ما يحصل قال هذه الاتهامات مثيره
للشفقه وانها اضطهاد سياسي نشاهد ترامب
بسيارته يستقل سيارته في هذا اليوم
التاريخي اذا ترامب يغادر مبنى محكمه
منهاتن بعد توجيه الاتهامات له اول رئيس
امريكي في المنصب او سابق توجه له اتهامات
جنائيه
عاما وجهت له هيئه المحلفين الاتهامات في
قضيه تتعلق اذا بدفع اموال لشراء صمت نجمه
الافلام الاباحيه
وقد افرج عن الرئيس الامريكي السابق
بكفاله لكي يتم اطلاق سراحه
واخلاء سبيله لكي يذهب الى قبل ان تبدا
المحاكمه لاحقا وهذا كما قلنا قد يطول
بشكل كبير ربما نتحدث عن اشهر طويله او
حتى عن عام يعني اشهر عشيه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله التي قد يكون مرشحا لها
اذا موكب ترامب يغادر محكمه من هاته بعد
اخلاء سبيله يعني طاهر اليوم
مثل الرئيس السابق امام المحكمه الجنائيه
كاي مواطن امريكي سقطت حصنته التي كان
يتمتع بها هي محاكمه غير مسبوقه لرئيس
امريكي سابق كان في السلطه ناديه كيف
تصفين هذا المشهد ونحن نشاهد ترامب يغادر
محكمه من هاتا
مشهد سوريالي كما ذكر طاهر قبل قليل بان
ياتي الرئيس السابق الذي له هيبه
المكان البيت الابيض قبل قليل كنت استمع
الى بعض التعليقات على المحطات الامريكيه
الذين قالوا ربما للمره الاولى لا يوجد
لشخص يفتح الباب حتى للرئيس عليه ان يدخل
المحكمه لوحدي ان يدفعني الباب لوحده
وبالتالي يفقد يعني هيبه رئيس الدوله
العظمى للعالم ولو حتى كان رئيس سابق
الرؤساء السابقين لديهم مكانه حتى كلمه
اعتقال الان طبعا رايناه وهو يخرج مع
محاميه الذين بقوا معه وايضا هناك مستشار
شخصي ايضا معه واتجه يتجه الموكب الان
سيغادر هذه المدينه التي تركها طواعيه ولا
يعني لا يوجد بينه وبين نيويورك كبير رغم
انه عقد معظم الصف التجاريه التي جعلت
منهم ملياردار هنا في نيويورك وهو يعني
كانت مدينته وكان بيته هنا على مدى عقود
ذهب الى فلوريدا ليبحث عن مكان اخر منذ ان
طبعا ترك البيت الابيض ويريد ان يدخل
معترك الحياه السياسيه مره اخرى من اوسع
ابوابها وهو باب الترشح للانتخابات 20 24
الى انه نرى على الشاشه اعذريني على
المقاطع نرى على الشاشه في جانب منها
التحضيرات للمؤتمر الصحفي الذي سيعقده
مدعي عام منحاه الفن دراك بعد قليل بعد
نحو ربع ساعه
تقريبا وفي الجانب الاخر نتابع مشاهده
موكب ترامب بعشر سيارات في هذا
الموكب حيث يتوجه الى المطار بعد اخلاء
سبيله من المحكمه بعد مغادره مبنى المحكمه
اخلاء سبيله بكف اله وبانتظار كلمه مدعي
عام منهاتا بعد قليل اذا ترامب يغادر
المحكمه بعد مثوله امامها في جلسه تاريخيه
وانضم الينا من واشنطن بيترشين نعضو الحزب
الديمقراطي واستاذ القانون في جامعه
نيويورك اهلا بك سيد بيتر يعني كيف يتابع
الحزب الديمقراطي هذا الحدث الذي وصفه
ترامب بالسيريالي
هل تسمعني السؤال
سيد بيتر اسالك عن نظرتك وكيف يتابع الحزب
الديمقراطي هذا اليوم هذه المحاكمه
من المؤكد
ان هذا الحدث بالنسبه للحزب الجمهوري
الذين ينظرون ان كافه هذه التهم الموجهه
الى ترامب هي مفبركه وان الادعاء يعد
مسيسا
ولا اعتقد انه من المرجح
سوف يثني مؤيدي ترامب عن مؤازرته في حملته
الانتخابيه وانا متاكد ان هناك البعض في
الحزب الجمهوري الذين لا يشعرون بالرضا
على ان رئيسا سابقا للولايات المتحده يضع
نفسه في هذا المازق وقد لا يرغبون
بترشيحهم احد الشخصيات التي قد تعرضت لهذه
المحنه لكن بالنسبه
بالنسبه لشخصيه الرئيس ترامب فهذا امر كان
يعرف عنه حتى قبل هذه الاتهام ولن يغير اي
شيء من شعبيته في ضمن حزبه الخاص
بيتر ام بي سي تقول الان ان الادعاء ابلغ
القاضي ان منشورات ترامب على منصته تروس
سوشل غير مسؤوله
ماذا يعني ذلك على الصعيد القانوني فيما
يتعلق بهذه بلائحه الاتهام وبالمحاكمه
وماذا يمكن ان يعني ايضا على صعيد قرارات
المحكمه بخصوص حظر النشر
نعم
لم انتبه الى الاجراءات التي قد حدثت ولا
اعلم اذا كان هناك امر بحذر نشر قد تم
اصداره لكنه ليس من المستغرب في قضيه ذات
صيتا واسع بان ان نجد
اتخاذ قرار بمثل مثل مثل ذلك
المدعى عليه في مثل هذه القضايا الذي كان
يهدد من خلال تصريحاته
وفي مواجهه الادعاء العام الامر الذي يراه
البعض بانه يشكل تهديدا لسلامه المدعي
العام بالاضافه للقضاه في المحكمه
ولا ارى بان هذا امر غير مسبوق
لفرض امر بحذر النشر في ظل هذه الاحداث
ومنع الرئيس السابق من الانخراط في مثل
هذه الممارسات
لكن لا يجدر بي ان اقول ان هذه التصريحات
لن تغير من طبيعتها الدفاع ومن طبيعه
التهم الموجهه اليه
دكتور ادمون غريب الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بك دكتور ادمومن واشنطن
انضميت الينا ما لعب الاخلاقي والقانوني
الذي يعني
سيخلفه ترشيح حزب الجمهوري في حال خروج
دونالد ترامب من هذه التهم بريئا يعني
نتحدث عن اول مره يتم ترشيح رئيس للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بسجل جنائي
من ناحيه
لا يجب الانتظار لمعرفه ما ستكون عليه
النتائج ونتائج المحاكمه
طبعا هناك
كما نرى الان هناك التفاف على الاقل حتى
الان حول الرئيس السابق هذا الالتفاف تعزز
خلال الايام الاخيره حيث ان نسبه الدعم
للرئيس وصلت الى 56% من الجمهوريين
وبينما
وهو المنافس الاقوى حتى الان ايضا
يحصل فقط على حوالي 24
نقطه وبالتالي فان هذا يظهر بان الرئيس
ترامب لا يزال يحظى بدعم قاعده واسعه
عريضه من بين الجمهوريين الذين يعتقدوا
بانه هو استهدف منذ اليوم الاول لوصوله
الى البيت الابيض وان التهم مثلا ب له
علاقه مع الروس وان الرسل
ادخلوه او ساعدوه على الوصول الى البيت
الابيض ثم ثبت بعد ذلك ان كل هذا كان هراء
ولم يكن له
اساس من الصحه كذلك ايضا كانت هناك الكثير
من الاتهامات الاخرى التي قيل بانه هو
الذي حرض على احداث
سته يناير ولكن طبعا هناك الان الصور
الاخيره التي نشرت والتي وافق رئيس مجلس
النواب على نشرها وظهرت على التلفزيون وان
كانت هناك معارضه قويه من الديمقراطيين
لذلك اظهرت بان المساله لم تكن كما قال
بعض عدد كبير من الديمقراطيين ومن وسائل
الاعلام بانه كان هناك حاله تمرد واصيان
ومحاولات لاسقاط النظام
اخبار عاجله عن طبيعه التهم التي وجهت
نيويورك تقول الان انه جميع التهم
المواجهه لترامب من الدرجه اي وهي ادنى
درجه من التهم
الجنائيه اضافه الى اتهام ترامب من قبل
يعني في تصريحات للمدعي العام الان بنسمع
منه اكثر بعد قليل تفاصيل ما يقول وفي
اعاده الكلام عن موضوع تزوير السجلات
التجاريه من الدرجه الاولى نحن بانتظار
وصول المدعي العامه اذا تقول ايضا انه
اقصى عقوبه للتهم الموجهه الى ترامب هي
السجن لاربع سنوات اخر المعلومات المتوفره
اذا حول طبيعه هذه التهم وما يمكن ان ينتج
عنها اسمح لي
بالشق القانوني
اعود اليه عضو الحزب الديمقراطي واستاذ
القانون بيتر شين ما رايك بهذه المعلومات
استاذ بيتر في طبيعه التهم التي وجهت كلها
من الدرجه اي كما تقول نيويورك تايمز وهي
ادنى درجه من التهم الجنائيه
وبانه ممكن انه تكون عقوبتها اربع سنوات
من السجن
اعتقد انه من غير المرجح ان الرئيس السابق
حتى لو تمت ادانته سوف يتم سجن
على الجرائم التي ارتكبت على الجرائم التي
ارتكبها الا اذا ما كانت هذه الجرائم تحمل
في طبيعتها طابعا خطيرا لكن
نحن لا نتحدث عن عن
تصرفاتي عنف او بعد التصرفات قد تدفع
للزجه به الى السجن
لدى متوقع على نطاق واسع
بانه بانه قد يتم ادانته في عدهم لكن من
غير المرجح بان يتم به في السجن نعم حتى
لو كان ذلك متعلق باخفاء معلومات عن
الناخبين بانه هو الاتهام الان يقول بانه
اخفى يعني زور سجلات تجاريه لاخفاء
معلومات عن الناخبين
واضافه الى ما يقوله الان مدعي عاما هاتا
عن ان ترامب حاول تقويض
مدى نزاهه انتخابات 2016
القانون هنا في نيويورك يعد معقدا الى
درجه ما فهناك قانون عام
فيما يخص
بتزوير السجلات التجاريه وهذا يعد جنحه
لكن اذا ما كانت دافع وراء تزوير
المستندات يرمي الى اخفاء جريمه اخرى
فالسؤال المطروح هو ما هي تلك الجريمه
الاخرى التي تم اخفائها وهذا الامر حتى
اللحظه لم يتم توجيه تهمه به واستنتاجاتي
من خلال ما سمعته ومقاله المدعي العام حتى
اللحظه ان الجريمه التي قد تكون اصليه هي
وتمت التغطيه عليها هي جريمه التامر من
اجل منع اي نوع من تحقيق الانتخابات
والنتائج انتخابات بطريقه غير مشروعه وهي
قد تكون محاوله لتغطيه
قد يقوله المدعي العام وفقا
للاحداث التي جرت في تمويل حملته
الانتخابيه وهذا قد تكون وهذا قد يكون جزء
من طبيعه الاحد الاتهام هذه الجريمه من
ضمن السلسله من الجرائم لكن من اجل ان
تكون جريمه
جنائيه فهي قد لا تكون فقط مرتبطه بمساله
تزوير المستندات بل يجب ان يثبت بانه قد
تم تزويرها من اجل غرض جنائي اخر
غير الجريمه الاصليه وهذا ما سوف يجعلها
جريمه جنائيه
غريب دكتور ادمو يعني مدعي عام يتحدث بانه
سلبيه خلال فتره رئاسته وبانه متهم ايضا
بتزوير سجلات الاعمال ضمن نشاط جنائي سري
وحاول تقويد نزاهه انتخابات عام 2016 عاده
حسب اغلب الخبراء القانونيين من المرجح ان
يتم الحكم بهذه القضايا في حال اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الاجراءات
وتكتيكات التاجير التي قد يلجا اليها فريق
ترامب
قانوني قد تاخذ الى ما بعد الانتخابات
وبالتالي سيستفيد من هذه المماطله سياسيا
وقانونيا
هناك عده نقاط اولا نتفق بعض ذكرها
بوضيفكم الكريم فيما يتعلق بان هذه لا
ترتقي ما لم تكن هناك معلومات تدل على ان
هناك كانت محاوله لتحقيق شيء اخر اخطر من
موضوع
التزوير او الاحتيال على السجلات التجاريه
ومحاوله دفع المال
للحفاظ على صمت الممثله الاباحيه لان هذه
لا تعتبر
الترجمه جاهزه نستمع اليها
اذا نتابع
هيئه دفاع ترامب وهي تجيب على اسئله
الصحافيين
ومدعي عاما يعني بعده تصريحات ومواقف
يتحدث بانه ترامب قدم 280 الف
لا يوجد اي سيناريو لوجودنا هنا الا
للاستماع للائحه الاتهامات التي تم كشف
النقاب عنها
هل تعتقدون ان ما يتم الحديث عنه بشان
احداثه يناير ان هذا امر واقعي ماذا بشان
حاله الوحده بين صفوفي
المواطنين
قلت كنا نعمل سويا
ومن خلال الجمله من المحاميين وانه لشرف
لي ان اعمل مع هذا الرجل فاننا فريق واحد
ما هي الخطوه المقبله
والمصطفى
متى سوف تقدمون
سوف تتقدمون بطلبات الى المحكمه لرد
هذه الدعوه
انتم تفهمون القصه ان
المدعي العام
هو الذي بدا
بتقديمي لائحه الاتهامات هذه
بناء على ما خلص اليه
المحلفون
تغيير
مقر المحاكمه
لم لم نتطرق الى اي نقاشات في هذا السؤال
في هذا الموضوع
وعايز ايه
هو عايز
لماذا يسعل لنقل مكان المحاكمه اننا ثلاثه
محاميين هنا نحارب من اجل هذه القضيه نحن
لسنا مستشارين بوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لقد وصل الرئيس ترامب الى سده الحكم
وبصرف النظر عما كان يكتبهم الرسائل على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لا يمكننا ان
نعلق على ما يكتبه من تعليقات على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
لا استطيع ان اخبركم ما الذي ناقشناه
بصوره اساسيه
لكن الحديث عن القاضي والحديث عن اسرتي
لكن
بالنسبه لاي مودع عام اخر لو كان هناك اي
مدعي عام مدعي عليه اخر فلن يكون موجودا
في هذه القاعه
قيل بان الذكر بان ترامب بانه غاضب من
المدعي العام وقد لا تتفقون مع ما اشار
اليه
انه مستعد للقتال
للقتال في المعركه
هل تعتقدون ان هذه توم سوف تبقى كلا بكل
تاكيد
[تصفيق]
تبعنا جانبا من هذا التصريح الصحفي لهيئه
دفاع تشامبو وكان منذ قليل رويترز طاهر
نقلت عن القاضي مطالبته للادعاء وفريق
ترامب بعدم الادلاء بتصريحات تحرض على
العنف طبعا
الان تنقل بانه جلسه الاستماع المقبله
لترامب ستكون في الرابع من ديسمبر في
نيويورك وكانت محكمه منهات الجنائيه منحت
ترامب اطلاقها سراح غير مشروط صحيح يعني
عاده يكون هناك بعض القيود التي تفرض على
اي يعني متهم حتى تتم محاكمته وادانته من
عدمها نسال عن سبب ذلك باعتقادك استاذ
بيترشين
الخطوه المقبله
بالنسبه للادعاء العام
سوف يستمروا بتجميع الادله من خلال
مداولات مع المحكمه
وسوف يتم
اطلاعي المحامين
على طبيعه تلك
الادله وسوف يقوم محمد الدفاع بضحدها
والدستور يقضي بان يعلم المدع عليه
بطبيعه التهم الموجهه اليه واي ادله قد
تقدم بحقق لذا هذه هي عمليه اكتشاف الادله
وقد يكون هناك
اجتماع او مؤتمر بعد عده اشهر من الان مع
المحكمه للنظر في وضع هذه القضيه من
الجانبين
وانا لن اكون مندهشا
اذا ما عمل فريق اترمت من المحامين على
رفع عده طلبات امام المحكمه من اجل رد هذه
الدعاوى الافتقارها الى المسببات الفنيه
القانونيه
وقد وقد يرون بان وقد يدعون او يتحججون
بان المده العام يقوم
بعدم توجيه
النصوص الدستوريه بشكلها الصحي
قد يكون هناك عده طلبات تقدم من فريق
محامي ترامب هذا يعتمد على تحليل محتوى
لائحه الاتهامات والادله التي قد يقدمها
الادعاء العام الى المحامين قد تقدم طلبات
من جانب الدفاع وسوف ياخذ المدع العام
وقته للرد عليها وفقا للاجراءات القضائيه
الى حين المحاكمه خاصه وانا جازفت محامي
احد محامي الرئيس السابق قال اتهام الرئيس
السابق يؤكد ان سياده القانون ماتت في هذه
البلاد وان يعني لا مؤشرات على ارتكاب
الرئيس السابق لاي جريمه فيدراليه واتهام
الرئيس السابق امر محبط وحزين ومستعدون
للقتال كما ختم حديث قبل قليل
يقول بانه ترامب بدفع اموال لعامل في برجه
لشراء صمته حول انجابه طفل خارج الزواج
اعود اليك دكتور يعني كل هذه التهم وكانها
الى حد ما هي بين شخصيه بين الدفع رشا وهي
ليست باتهامات خطيره ليست باتهامات هي جنح
من الناحيه القانونيه حسب ضيفنا هي جنا
حتى انه
قادما هاتا قال بان المحاكمه قد تبدا بعام
2024 وبانه جلسه الاستماع المقبله ستكون
في الرابع من ديسمبر في نيويورك
هل نحن امام محاكمه سياسيه لا قانونيه بحث
تهدف فقط يعني تشويه ربما الصوره ترامب
هكذا يقول الجمهوريون
ويعني تخفيف حظوظه بربح الانتخابات
القادمه
فعلا اولا هذه القضيه هي جنا وحتى لو كانت
لشخص اخر فانه كان سيتم لم يتم
تتمه هذه الاجراءات
والتوجيه الاتهامات حتى ان المدعي العام
الذي سبق
السيد براي رفض ذلك وبراك نفسه عندما اثير
الموضوع في البدايه لم يتابعه وبالتالي
فان هذا يظهر بان هذه القضيه ليست هي
قضيه تصل الى مستوى الجنايه محاوله براجن
يفعله هو ان يربط دفع الاموال
للميه وتلاتين الف دولار و 150 بغض النظر
عن الرقم
هذه هي
يربطها حاول ان يربطها باخفاء معلومات
للتاثير على الانتخابات ولكن هذه حدثت قبل
2016 وعلى الرغم من ذلك لم نرى من المدعين
العامين الذين تابعوا هذا يظهر بان هناك
على الاقل بعد سياسي بالاضافه الى البعد
القانوني وكذلك كانت احدى اهداف براج
عندما رشح نفسه لمنصب المدعي العام وفي
ولايه في منطقه منهج التي هي ذات غالبيه
ساحقه من الديمقراطيه طبعا هذه قد يكون
لها تداعيات وتاثير على الانتخابات
بالنسبه
الان بالنسبه للموضوع حاليا وهذا على
الاقل ما يقوله الجمهوريون ولكن ايضا هناك
سنرى اذا كان هناك اي اثباتات اخرى كانت
هناك معلومات اخرى التي ستدين ترامب وترفع
هذه القضيه من مستوى الجنحه الى مستوى
الجنايه وحتى الان يبدو على الاقل طبعا
يجب لانه لا يمكن فقط الاعتماد على ما
سمعناه حتى الان لانه يجب قراءه كل ما تم
كل لائحه الاتهامات التي له حتى الان يبدو
ان هذه تساعد ترامب بين الجمهوريين واجبرت
او ضغطت على القيادات الجمهوريه التي يوجد
عدد كبير منها الذين لا يحبون ترامب او
يعتقدون انه هو يسيء سمعه الحزب او يشكل
ضرر على الحزب هؤلاء اضطروا الى الوقوف
الى جانب ترامب والى دعمه حتى الان تبقى
معنا
يعني الان يقول بانه المحاكمه يمكن ان
تبدا في يناير 20 24 ومراسلتنا ناديه
البلبيسي تنقل ان اتهامات تم تقديمها في
16 صفحه معلومات جديده لديها نعود نعود
بها
اذا بعد قليل لناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن تنضم الينا من نيويورك
مجددا ونذكر بان محامي
تشامبينا كان تعهد بمحاربه الاتهام النمطي
كما سماه واليائس الموجه لموكله وبانه دفع
اموالا
الامراتين والعامل في برجه لكي يخفي قصه
انجابه خارج الزواج طبعا كل ذلك في سياق
تحضيره للانتخابات التي فاز بها في عشرين
سته عشر نعود اذا طيب نستمع الى زوجتك
كان يتحدث مجددا يبدو انه انتهى لي التو
وكاميرات الصحفيين واسئله المراسلين
تلاحقه من كل صوب واتجاه الان انهى ولكن
نقلنا طبعا ابرز ما قاله راويه صحيح اذا
نشاهد في الصوره موكب ترامب الذي يغادر
منهاتا الى فلوريدا طبعا الملياردير
الجمهوري الذي تولى رئاسه من 2017 الى
2021 يطمح طبعا للعوده الى البيت الابيض
ولكن تلاحقه الاتهامات
يعني نحن بحاجه لبعض الوقت حتى نتمكن من
قراءه 16 صفحه طبعا باللغه الانجليزيه
وترجمتها الى العربيه لكن حتى الان انا لم
ارى اي مفاجات عدا على ان الرئيس اتهمه
بالفعل بدفع هذه الاموال لثلاثه اشخاص كنا
نعرف على ان الثور من دانيلز هي اشهر هذه
الاشخاص الثلاثه وبعدها كان المكدور
مكذوبه والان نتحدث عن هذا العامل لم نكن
نعرف عنه لكن يبدو بان هناك معلومات جمعها
المدعي العام واضافها هنا وكل هذا هو في
اطار الانثى رشح للانتخابات عام 2016 وان
الرئيس حاول التلاعب في هذا
وشراء صمت هؤلاء الاشخاص طبعا محامي
الرئيس قبل قليل كان خلفي هنا كان الاعلام
يوجه له بعض الاسئله والشرطه تحاول ان ان
ربما تحصر نطاق المقابلات في منطقه معينه
فقط حتى لا يحدث هناك عمليه ان انا اتمكن
من الذهاب لاني كنت على الهواء طوال هذه
الساعات لكن طبعا ربما لا مفاجاه وهذا عدم
وجود مفاجاه يسهل عمل محامي الرئيس ترامب
لانهم يدركون سابقا ما هي هذه الاتهامات
وسيعدون لها لكن ايضا المفاجاه بانه كنا
نتوقع بانه قد يكون القاضي قد قرر بان
يغلق ملف هذه القضيه وانه لم يكن هناك
ادله كافيه لكن يبدو بان القاضي طبعا سمح
للمدعي العام الاستمرار في هذه القضيه
ووضع حتى تاريخ بدء هذه المحاكمه لاحقا
وسنرى ماذا سيفعل الرئيس الليله لكن ايضا
الرئيس الان يبدو مكبلا نوعا ما لانه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي التي اعتمد عليها
ترامب بشكل اساسي للتواصل مع
مناصريه ومؤيديه يبدو بانها ستكون تحت
المجهر الان عليه ان يكون حذرا
وحتى لا يفسر بانه تحريض وهذا ما قاله
واشتكى منه المدعي العام الذي وصفه الرئيس
ترامب انه حيوان بين قوسين على فكره قال
بانه في السابق والان ليس فقط هي استخدام
توصيفات غير لائقه لكن نتحدث اذا كان
بالفعل قد وجه الرئيس معلومات او تصريحات
او ربما اشارات الى مؤيديه بان يقوموا
بالاحتجاج او بارتكاب بعض الاعمال التي قد
تنقلب الى اعمال عنف هذا سيكون نقطه ستسجل
ضد الرئيس ترامب الذي كما ذكرنا توجه الى
مارلاجو والان سنستمع معا خلال اربع ساعات
من الان عما سيقولوا للشعب الامريكي يصل
الان كما نرى في هذه الصور الى مطار
لاغوار
الرئيس هذه الصور نراها مباشره اذا لوصول
موكب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الى مطار لاغوارديا مجددا كنا بالامس في
مثل هذه الساعه
ايضا رصدنا وصوله والان نرصد مغادرته
مجددا الى فلوريدا الى مارالاجو حيث
سنستمع اليه ايضا بعد ساعات كما ذكرت
ناديه بعد ما اطلقت المحكمه الجنائيه في
منهات
سراحوا دون ان تفرض عليه اي شروط كما قلت
قبل قليل راويه او مراقبه قضائيه على اثر
هذه بدء هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه
هذه الساعه وهذه التغطيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ناديه ولباقي مراسلينا وايضا ضيوفنا في
هذه الساعه التي كانت مخصصه
لمتابعه هذه التغطيه وهذه المحاكمه
التاريخيه التي تحصل للمره الاولى في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التغطيه
طبعا مستمره مع الزميله ميسونا شكرا
للمتابعه